desde que empezó el terremoto del pasado
lunes por la madrugada los aeropuertos
que aún funcionan de la región que no
son todos se han llenado de personas que
intentan evacuar esta región afectada
del sureste de Turquía ahora mismo un
aeropuerto de adana muchísimas personas
se agolpan para intentar uno de
los aviones que salen de este aeropuerto
en dirección sobre todo a Estambul
ankara y ahí las tres grandes ciudades
de Turquía normalmente en ese aeropuerto
saldrían el día en torno a 34 aviones a
estas ciudades ahora mismo salen casi a
cada hora son aviones mandados por la
gran compañía turca de Aviación Turquía
Airlines que ha metido más aviones en
este en este calendario de vuelos y son
todos gratuitos para todo el mundo que
queda poder salir de esta región en
dirección a otras ciudades del país para
intentar si de esas personas afectadas
esta región no tienen casa ir a convivir
con sus familiares en otras provincias
de tu